la resiliencia en el amor en medio del
turbulento momento que atraviesan
diversas latitudes en el mundo San
Valentín representa para muchos un día
de esperanza en Jordania una tienda de
chocolates donará todas las
recaudaciones del día a Los afectados
por el terremoto que azotó Siria y
Turquía esta iniciativa animó a decenas
de jordanos a demostrar que el amor
tiene diferentes formas y significados
quería hacer de este San Valentín un día
de amor y apoyo a nuestros hermanos en
Siria y Turquía el amor no es solo el
amor común que conocemos en este día
sino también el amor de una madre o de
un padre a su hijo el amor de los hijos
hacia sus familias el amor de las
personas entre sí y el amor entre
naciones diferentes
en Ucrania El sentimiento es compartido
en medio de la guerra que enfrenta su
país los residentes de kievs salieron a
las calles a comprar flores y diversos
detalles para sus seres queridos No se
olvidan de la Guerra sin embargo el 14
de febrero representa un Oasis en medio
del desierto para muchos ucranianos
intentamos aguantar sí lo celebramos con
un poco de tensión pero intentamos
aguantar gracias a San Valentín nos
distraemos de la guerra de estos
acontecimientos
este año el concepto de San Valentín
sale de los estándares del romanticismo
tradicional en los territorios
palestinos la venta de regalos disminuyó
y en gasa culpan del descenso a los
enfrentamientos recientes con las tropas
israelíes